so I just played in the world's largest
duck chess Arena good friend of mine
Katarina and them Silva had her birthday
earlier today and she held what I'm
pretty sure is the largest ever online
duck chess tournament and I streamed the
whole thing and I tried to win the whole
thing and you're gonna see all my games
in this video that were live streamed
with commentary and if you're new to
duck chess it's uh pretty simple to
understand and and follow the games
essentially the duck is a blocker so it
cannot be captured it can't be moved
through and with every turn you make a
normal chess move and then you move the
duck to a new empty square and it just
creates a whole new world of different
ideas and possibilities and craftix so I
do hope you enjoy the video and before
we get to the duck chess I do want to
give a big thank you to today's sponsor
which is athletic greens now athletic
greens makes a nutritional drink called
ag1 that I've been taking every morning
for the past several weeks now and it's
super simple I just add one travel pack
or one scoop into 12 ounces of water
every morning and The Taste is actually
really good there's no artificial
flavors or preservatives but there are
75 different ingredients including
vitamins superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens as a chess player it's so
important to stay as healthy as possible
during travels and competition ag-1 has
energy supporting ingredients to keep
you alert also supports nervous system
and hormone function to improve mental
clarity now for me taking ag1 has been
an effortless daily habit I took it
recently during my travels to Toronto
and I very much look forward to taking
it during my next chess tournament so I
can receive all the benefits that it
offers so if you want to try ag1 and
experience all of its benefits you can
click the link below athleticgreens.com
Eric Rosen to get started on your order
and athletic greens is going to give my
community a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d3k2 and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase so I really hope it brings you
as much benefit as it's brought to me
thank you again Allied greens for
sponsoring this video and now let's get
back to the chest
okay I've joined
oh wow A lot of people are joining
I hope the servers don't crash
I'm playing this person
okay let's go this is the biggest duck
chess tournament
maybe ever probably for like in the
history of the world
just finished a Spanish lesson oh
yoke hero Pato delicioso
or yokiro part of wait Papa I forgot how
to speak Spanish
Pato Fuerte por favor
okay
so we have we have an interesting
opening
I'm trying to go for the early trade of
Bishop for Knights
oh Knight D7
Play Bishop E3
now I want to play D4 maybe I should
have played
maybe I should have played like Duck D4
not sure though
box spending a lot of time moving this
Knight
so again for those new to duck chess
uh hopefully you can
get a sense of the rules just by
watching
but um
yeah there's a lot of different strategy
and
galactics compared to normal chests
and there's also just a lot of
positional ideas to
quack quack I really want to play this
move
and then this
so preventing the queen from returning
I am maybe losing a pawn
but that has to be really really careful
here
I guess there there is Queen takes B2
and duck B1
and then oh no my Rook
quack quack thank you Orange Crush
this will probably go on YouTube
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube
uh then you probably know that this made
it to YouTube
oh no someone call an ambulance
but not for me
okay we have the first smothered duck
mates
12 move game
GG let's move on to the next game
yeah Knight D5
I think it was was overwhelming for
black there
I think Queen takes B2 and duck d8 could
have been played for black then then it
would have been interesting
so we can view the sandings
some people have won their first game
playing Master virage whose profile
picture is a duck
oh wow
hello future for me on YouTube we are
eight months old
hey shout out to Future Shaggy Pike
okay so this is game number two this is
a 90 minute tournament
uh I guess I'll develop like this
I want to put the bishop on G4
and now I want to trade Bishop for
Knights
I'm threatening another smothered Doug
mate
oppon's gonna play Bishop G2 though yeah
what to do
let's play this and then this also thank
you Lele
appreciate the raid
hope you had a good stream
okay no mercy
can I
I want to prevent Rook G1
attacking the bishop
oh okay that's another smothered duck
meat
I can't stop myself
the knights are too powerful
okay next game
yeah the combination of the horsey and
the ducky
is very dangerous
not even an ambulance would save white
in that position
okay playing Alan Stillman
good luck to my opponent
I'm not sure if Katarina is playing she
might just be doing commentary
maybe people can tune into her Channel
and let me know
but I know a lot of like strong
well-known chess players are playing
I'm pretty sure Yasser sarawan is
playing
and David Navara
a handful of other Grandmasters
there's not too much time between games
to look at the standings
welcome back I'm pink therefore I'm spam
happy 18 months
yeah during a game I can't look at the
standings it's only between games
I can take a look
so I'm preventing castling I'm two moves
away from smothered duck mate
oh
Let's uh let's defend
I should probably play this
I didn't want to allow Bishop G5
oh she is playing oh that's cool
um let's play this move
okay maybe G5
being aggressive here
some idea to play G4
a common strategy is to attack a piece
and then take away that piece's light
Square
although the Knight loo before I could
actually attack it
at some point these Knights will
probably be traded
yeah I think this is probably going to
be my most difficult game so far
it's like the first two games I won in
the first uh what like 12 moves
um
okay I'm preventing C4
and Bishop C4
and I want to take this
maybe I could have played duck F6 sir
to ensure that uh
oh wow so white threatening mate but uh
I can take
and let's play this move
yeah so far this is all um
kind of all Fair Trades
I played DACA Fort uh guarantee Knight
F4
so an event of C4 I played Knight F4 and
probably duck D2
or even
neither for duck G4
no I have to prevent Bishop F4
so duck D2
so I'm turning this and this
yeah Knight and Bishop is probably
better than the bishop pair unlike
normal chess
thank you
that's a very fine move
play this and this
and this move might be coming
I mean the Knight will have multiple
options
I have to keep preventing the Bishop
from taking the knights
so if
I mean if the duck keeps returning to D6
I have to find a different idea
uh to do
G4 maybe H5 first
and G4 guaranteeing Pawn G4
again there's a lot of people tuning in
who uh are confused about the duck the
duck's a blocker
um it can't be captured Can't Be Moved
Through
every turn you have to move it to a new
empty Square
um
and there's a lot of the strategy
surrounding how to deal with a duck
let's play this
so I'm saving the Knight I'm still
wanting to play G4
wait did I just miss no
okay so I'm still hitting the queen kind
of
I'm also hitting the pawn now
yeah there's a lot of different things
attached
and the duck can only block so much
like the duck might return to D6 oh
I'll take and
duck
duck D4
I'm gonna win the pawn
maybe a five at some point
yeah I think I'll be winning on time
very soon
foreign
please help me with a little investment
im a little short on money oh no your
money
not sure if I can help you out
but
uh good luck with your endeavors
oh this is so close to winning
but not quite
if I listen to this
wanna play this move
there we go
oh no White's Queen
no mercy
everything's like under pressure too
no mercy
okay GG that was the hardest [ __ ]
thus far for me
okay I'm throughout the three
a lot of people with two
next opponent
oh coaster kabutski is playing
yeah I'm not sure how much time I'm
gonna have to really like explore in the
standing so much
but uh
okay I'm gonna try and get in as many
games as possible
that's one of the goals with uh an arena
tournament
I'm holding on to the pawn
obeseries played two GMS in a row oh wow
I played zero GM thus far
this is my fourth game
okay guaranteeing Knight C3
I could have prevented Bishop B7
I'm giving the option of Bishop G4 which
at first looks like a good move but
um I would likely play 95 and like Duck
F3
okay so I'm holding onto the pawn
um no need to make predictions for this
tournament
I'm just trying to enjoy the games
uh can I play this
I'll just block the bishop
at some point I'll probably like revamp
Channel points but I know currently
there's not too many Channel Point
Rewards
um it's one of the challenges with
just having a lot of viewership in
general
so
we'll keep it chill
there is a hollow Redemption hello to
Milford
let's play this and
keep improving
yeah this is one example of how things
can
be very difficult for black like early
in the opening
I do have to be careful though like each
six and then like Duck F4
I mean I assume I'm gonna have enough
counter play
oh I could have played I could play G4
a missed opportunity
okay now I'm going after the king
yeah I realize I don't need people to
tell me to sit T in order for me to sift
tea
I I said tea uh regardless
of a huge mug of this Japanese sensha
okay so now the Knight essentially has
to move to F6 to save itself
the goal is to play Knight E4
I'm trying to stir up some attack here
like Bishop D5 is interesting but that
was allow Knight F6
and then duck duck somewhere
is this just gonna be meat
I think this is me like
oh it's not me
it's really close to me though
so there is basically three things
attacking the king
like if Knight takes
wait what just happened
oh that's what happened oops
I kind of messed up
let's play this
Oh no you're all night
I really messed up
okay
I gotta make use of my time Advantage
I'm actually just worse here
that was such a good position too
uh let's play this
I'm I'm giving away a rook I'm going
absolutely crazy here
I'm threatening duck made in one with
Queen D7 duck B8
okay one on time
oh that was confusing I could have
probably taken the free Bishop too
next game oh opponent said subscribe to
rusen
or not my opponent maybe just some
random person
okay four out of four let's go
oh spicy caterpillar and chess weebs two
Grandmasters
I was Ray Robson and Danish borosh
and playing someone who's provisional
yeah I'm not getting much rating for
winning these games
but that's okay
okay let's play this
I'll make mixing things up a little bit
trying to open the center quickly
okay I want to play E5
relatively soon
and basically I just want to develop
harmoniously Control Center and space
of
uh yeah I'll prevent Knight F3
Bishop B5 looks like a counter attack
but then I I take the Knight and block
the the chuck with the duck
okay now I have one goal Knight F3 with
a smothered mate
not even some other duck mates
okay two moves away
oh he's probably gonna prevent it I'm
allowing this
um
wait wait
a better way to handle this maybe this
first
preventing Bishop D2
so there is a strong move for white to
was to take in Ducks E3
but okay now let's go for this
I'm trying to chase the Knight to G2
if Knight takes Pawn I take back and
block the D file
I was already really really tricky for
white
okay let's block the file
blocking this diagonal too
so I got my two horses
yeah the horsies working together with
the duck
we're gonna see the magic they can pull
off
Knight C3 is a threat
and this is still an idea too
okay that's a free Bishop
so fun fact it is legal to Castle
through check because check is not a
thing in this game
um you can Castle through check
or in check
you can even you can Castle into chat
too
but uh usually not a good idea
oh chess sweeps in second place
oh I'm playing Custer wow well okay is
new to this game too
okay shout out to Costa
chess Dojo alive
oh degench says kosher beat me
okay I'll try and get revenge for you
no mercy here
oh Coast is also streaming shout out to
kosha
okay this is my go-to opening we'll see
how much Theory question is
okay he didn't play C4 unfortunately
so this is probably my most played
opening
like this um weird Scandinavian where I
went back upon
okay preventing castling
considering the
yeah maybe I will block the d-pawn I'm
allowing castling but
that's okay with me
I want to play Bishop G7 and if duck G7
then I play E6 and I'll find a way to
develop
ooh C4
so another four
yeah the light seems a little bit shaky
here but as long as white can't play D4
I think things are okay
play this move
and duck D3
maybe I'll Castle queenside
oh so B3 coming maybe
Queen D6
hmm
I think at some point I'll play F6
just ensuring that uh
the diagonal is not too vulnerable
because Bishop E5 was actually a threat
along with attacking The Rook too
foreign
maybe now Bishop H6
I'll keep logging the d-pawn there's a
funny line like G3
and let's say like Duck E6 I can play
Knight H3 duck G2 and then win the queen
so I have casting rights on both sides
the duck can only stop so much here
I think I want to play Bishop G4 next
like one strategy in Duck chess is to
create like multiple ideas
so the opponent can only block so much I
use blocking castling but okay now I
have this and duck
E2
[Music]
no I don't think I want that though
I want to get rid of the Knight
maybe at some point I'll Castle Queen
side
E5 is also an idea
oh wow
it's like Queen D5
I could have taken the pawn and like
Duck C3 or something
maybe I should have done that
but I like the prospect of like the
queen also pressuring the Knight
foreign
position for white here
B4
I'll play E5
I think the pawn wants to keep marching
up
quack
quack
foreign
E2 maybe pretty soon
yeah I have to keep the duck on E2 which
actually works out well because I keep
the bishop defended from the queen and I
prevent The Rook from attacking the pawn
Bishop takes I just take back and put
the duck back on you too
I'm trying to calculate like Queen like
some crazy Queen sack with Knight H3
I think I'll just Castle here
just to demonstrate that it's possible
to Castle while in check
and keep winning material
no mercy
I played this move this is actually a
cool move and then like Duck agent one
trying to attack
also quack
okay the the main thing is to not hang
the king
uh maybe this
and then this
yeah of course just tricky
play this and this
okay now I can play this and this oh
wait wait wait wait
oh it's so tricky
let's take the queen first
there we go
I'm up a rook here
I have some funny like Perpetual thing
mm-hmm
I gotta get the Rook involved
white surviving though that's impressive
uh let's play A3
it's kind of frustrating
three's coming
okay I just want to trade Bishops
okay I want on time good game coach
he fought on I thought I was gonna win
sooner
oh chess weeps in a second
oh Sam Savion is playing wow
Sam Sevin
Iliad niznik
tranquilizer also GM Ray Robson
so many so many like top players Nazi
pakizi
wow
okay a lot of people on my tail
do ducks have tails
or just tailbones
figure out what ducks have
uh let's play this
backslash quack
quack
quack
quack
quack oh dear quack
quack
will ever stop
quack
Le me backslashes
okay preventing Pawn E6
we'll probably see Pawn D6 but now both
Bishops can develop
and the duck can only block one Bishop
oh I just hung upon
kind of
yeah I hung upon
there's this and then this
oh
let's develop this
guaranteeing Bishop C4
yeah again for anyone new joining the
rules are on this sidebar
um
hopefully people can read this
we also have the duck command in chat
hopefully clear up any questions
okay so I'm ahead in development I want
to play Queen E2
oh can I play duck
let's start with
start with this
I was thinking about stacking
that's a cool idea to like sack
I think I will do this
[ __ ] G8
that's probably a little bit dubious but
it looks interesting
uh this and then
[Music]
um
yeah unfortunately I can't actually
like force the king up because the king
can go back to eat it
Rook D1 will come maybe Queen side
castling actually
keep forgetting I can Castle through
check
D7
so the queen reaches F7 that's one way
to end the game
I I actually saw this but I didn't think
it works because
something like this
the bishop can't retreat
and I'm hitting the queen as well
now there's this move
okay so the king bishop and queen are
all Targets
I'm not sure how black defends
everything
Bishop
no mercy
okay so I basically won back the bishop
that I sacrificed
did I miss a free Queen
oops I missed a free Queen
oh it's so easy to miss things in this
game
okay I think I'm meeting next move
it's very close to meat
because I'm going to be guaranteed Queen
F7
then I'll put the duck on d8
so there is one way for black to survive
is to put the duck on d8 but
yeah this is now winning
no mercy
I'm trying to reach 2200. the level of
duck master
yeah the free Queen was after uh Bishop
takes G2 The Rook was uh aligned
okay seven out of seven
the the people behind me have five out
of five
okay let's play this one
this is a new opening that um
I saw someone play the other day and it
looked interesting
uh I don't know what I want to do
limit the king side development
this is not a money tournament this is
just for fun
um it's probably the largest duck chest
tournament ever in history
so for everyone playing you're making
history today congratulations
and I am planning to put this whole
stream on YouTube
or at least a portion with the
tournament
I'm taking this very seriously to trying
to win games quickly
thank you pixie Dodger
okay ready to Castle
we might see duck f8 next
um oh
[Music]
opponent preventing my plans I'll play
94.
create some tension between the knights
it's not my birthday it's uh Prague
Queen's birthday actually
we have the prod Queen command
and she's also streaming on her Channel
I think she's also playing too
and she's the reason why like so many
players are playing in this event like
she got so many GMS to
accept their invitation
I don't want to trade off the night
though
I mean I might have to
old castle first
yeah it looks like all the knights are
just coming off the board
there's a question what cattle do you
use for your tea
um
I don't know the brand but I can
try and look it up and then include that
in the
T command
okay this is seemed like a mouse slip
I'm not sure if that was a mouse slip
but it's a very generous gift
my tea kettle does have temperature
control
because there's certain teas like green
tea you're supposed to boil usually
around 180 Fahrenheit to
um so a little bit below the boiling
temperature
I'm drinking this uh Japanese sencha
green tea
okay playing F5
um
I do have
actually let's not play offline let's
play on this move
one thing about duck chess if you make a
move but you don't place a duck
um you can undo the move
um which is nice
so it's one way to avoid slipping
but of course once you've placed a dock
then your move is final
I put but put the duck on F4 to
guarantee Pawn F4 eventually
I could have taken on B2
or D5 maybe I should have
but I'm going for the kill I'm gonna
play F3 next
a question about my hoodie
uh this hoodie it's um
yeah it's not my own merch but it's
actually it's a company that handles my
merch
they're called fourth wall
and uh
they actually sent me this hoodie as
like a kind of a sample of the material
[Music]
that I ended up using for my own hoodies
so it's actually the same material like
it's very soft very comfortable
we do have the merge command
if you place merch
it is uh in order through fourth wall
yeah it looked like I was in check it
looked like I was losing my queen but
the duck is very good at blocking checks
GG
okay eight out of eight at some point
I'm probably gonna play chess weeds
but not yet
okay so we have a Sicilian
I don't know so much Theory here Bishop
B5 looks natural
uh maybe this move
I'm trying to provoke Knight C6
I mean black is either gonna have to
play Knight C6 or duck C6 so
duck C6 it is now I'm preventing Pawn B5
and now I'm trying to induce Pawn B5
actually so if Pawn B5 I'll play Bishop
D5 I think I play it regardless
preventing Knight D4
okay
okay yeah I'm playing like very uh
aggressively this game
with the bishop
with the duck
I want to play F4 next
just trying to control the center
against space
maybe you move the bishop into
there's no berserk button no no
berserking in uh as far as I know on
chess.com that's not a thing
although I guess if you wanted to give
time odds you could wait
maybe 90 seconds before making your
first move
probably not the best strategy
queen of three
actually I have to be careful here queen
of three is not good
there's 94
394
very confrontational
so I'm hitting the queen allowing Queen
A5 or queen B4
yeah there's some risks of this
Queen B4 I think I'm actually losing a
knight
because it's a triple attack
although I do have uh I'm gonna lose a
bishop after E6
but maybe not because I can move it back
I put the duck ooh that move I missed
yeah I've kind of botched this
let's play this move
and then
this
yeah I'm I'm in a little bit of trouble
here
if I played C3 there was Queen takes A4
and then duck C2
or duck B3
yeah there's so many cases where
something will look defended but
uh the duck will block the defense
wow
that's a fancy move
okay I'm Gonna Save The Knight and then
duck
F3
saving my queen as well
okay I think this is a great example of
when it makes sense to trade
uh Rook for night
because long term the nights should be
worth more
multiply H3
if Bishop H5 I play G4 duck G3
no on plus song for you
I'm so close to trapping the queen
actually
I'm about to trap the queen with A3
and duck B5
preventing duck piece or queen B6
and the Knights control all these
squares Bishop controls this
and the duck can't really help Save the
Queen
on some nice uh a nice series Aquatics
anti-am passant
smothering the queen with my duck
Queen sacks would sell for the Knight
okay now I'm going after the pawn she
both Pawns
foreign
coming soon
this Pawn is still attacked too
preventing castling
if I put the duck on like anywhere else
then the king castle
was except for G8
I want to win the pawn next
oh
very fancy
so now I'm allowing castling
I'm realizing
um
yeah I could have played G5 duck D5
but that comes next
and essentially I'm removing the
defender of E4
so like when the night moves then the
duck has to move and I'll win the bishop
for free
every night doesn't move I win the night
for free
uh here I'll just take the Knight for
free
and put the duck back
okay up a queen
up enough material here
bring the Knight back in
I have a similar idea in my game against
Costa like Knight H6 and then duck
G7
it's really close to duck meat
it's kind of like a windmill
oh interesting
it's getting spicy
it's so close to meat
uh but where's the mate
in this and then this
King has to move to G7
and now this and then this
King G6 doc F6
okay
uh that was a nice finish
happy with that game chess weebs still
close behind
foreign
eight games
there's 39 minutes left in the
tournament
there we go
playing Road Runner oh who also I think
is doing pretty well
okay going back to my usual block
opening
not too many people are falling for this
trap like almost everyone's playing
Knight C3
unfortunately
but that's okay and get a playable
position
I still need to win a lot more games to
cross 2200 I'm gaining fractions of a
rating point with every win
but now going after this Pawn
oh G3
um G3 is new G3 is probably a good move
though
I wonder actually
I have to take
duck G2
I really want to put the bishop on G4
we might see C4 might see Bishop C4
foreign
preventing the d-pawn from moving
oh very sneaky
so my T3 doesn't work for me
unfortunately
I like Queen D3 Queen D3 duck E3 no it
doesn't work
okay let's move back
it looked like smothering me but I'd
have to move the dog and then I lose the
Knight
so this opponent is probably better than
the average duckling
hi do you want to go for this train
a knight D4 at some point
interesting
wow
a fascinating move
you play this
and then duck D3
so I'm defending the bishop and I'm
guaranteeing Knight D3 and hitting the
queen and hitting the pawn
very multi-purpose this is high level
qualitics happening
I want to play c62 to undermine the
bishop
Queen E2 wow
well maybe Queen D4
Queen d4.t3
so I defend uh it's important that I'm
defending at close range
this Knight can't be taken hitting the
pawn again
do you have to move a piece before
moving the duck yes
yeah you can't move a duck before moving
the piece
which I guess limits some possibilities
okay there's a some success
um
not sure where I want to put it
okay this move the Ducks returning to F1
or not wow
interesting
so if I take
I could just castle and duck F1
it's hard for a white to remove the
queen here
okay this is looking very good now
and D3 was just an oversight from lights
C4 is going to be falling soon
I'm guaranteeing Queen B3
and the king is kind of stuck on the D
file like it can't run I mean the duck
will probably find its way to block The
Rook but the combination of Rook Knight
and queen
the duck can only block so much
um
interesting so I have this
and then
put it back on D3
maybe there's some missed opportunities
there but uh this looks Pleasant
yeah preventing the king from
going all the way to safety
is this duck meat
and this is this is game over
that's duck mate
it doesn't look like document at first
but the duck is uh yeah it was basically
pinned to the king
the Knight controlling the getaway
squares
okay that was really Pleasant
oh chess sweeps is tied with me and it
has a slightly better performance rating
oh no
wow
okay I'm gonna have to play quicker
uh-huh
dirty flower play
very foul
just like a water vowel
I haven't been too many dirty Flags I
mean some games have ended with flags
but
they haven't been tutery
okay opponents are getting a bit
stronger
or at least a bit higher rated
I want to trade uh Bishop for Knights
we might see Knight ec6 and duck to E7
or not
sure how much this does
the queen D7 is coming
preventing the Bishop from taking the
Knight
black is actually pretty solid here
to play this
and then this
gonna have to be careful to
make things almost getting trapped
but C5 runs into Knight takes B5
oh good move
I have this move
okay preventing A4
tricky play on The Queen side
foreign
I duck slipped
I allowed Bishop takes Knight but
Black's not going for it wow
so Knight D5 looks very very attractive
and then maybe Duck
DC d8
foreign
I'm going after the D6 Pawn now
we might see Bishop E5 and then F4
has a very shaky position for black
though
you might see Queen C6
interesting
hmm
let's make progress here
I want to get the queen in now
and black is very restricted here and
knights are so powerful
thank you Rob
first time Prime sub
like the queen wants to come in the the
idea earlier was like 97 duck h8
almost smothered duck mate okay now 97.
is winning the queen
we might see a resignation
maybe not though
uh let's not plunder my queen
I should probably move my Queen off the
diagonal of the bishop
but yeah there's so many ideas so I'm
probably gonna win the pawn next
oh wait what
okay that was an accidental pre-move how
I did that
uh
I was just playing around with my pieces
okay now there's a picture of this
trapped
The Queen Is Almost trapped if the
bishop could move here and then duck G4
but duck F6 was important
foreign
yeah that's a nice thing like if I Mouse
slip pre-move I can just cancel the move
before placing the duck
no mercy
get away with this
no that's not a good move
really using my ability to cancel
cancel pre-moves and just cancel bad
moves
okay I want to take here next
never mind
okay GG
chass weebs and I are tied still wow
it's going to come down to the wire
okay going for this sign
um
let's play E5
yeah this is a more timid variation
[Music]
um
okay C6 and A6 maybe coming
it's actually already getting
interesting
maybe I can get away with winning the
bishop
you know it does have to be careful
I think Queen G5 is interesting like
Queen G5 attack of one
I'm trying to induce G3 so I can play
another three with some other duck mate
that would be fun and if takes take so
I'm threatening B5 and duck B3 but also
Queen takes G2 duck G1
so the projects are flowing as early as
move five
I thought this was going to be a more
like strategic slow opening
oh that's a good move actually
I guess I'll just develop
and block the d-pawn for moving
now the idea is to move the h-pong
gain space quack quack hope you're doing
well and taking care of yourself
I'm doing my best thank you uh
who is that
mate Ray thank you
I'm trying to take care of myself and my
duck
each four is annoying
let's play this and this
I want to play Bishop here
okay preventing I allowed D3 though
not the end of the world
there's a cool idea like this this and
duck H3
thank you Bacchus
oh this Queen's not getting out alive
no mercy
that's so much easier to trap pieces in
this game like even Queens
or especially Queens
thank you superhuman horse
this is like a superhuman duck
ing the queen
and once I take I should have enough
resources to attack
but it's still hard to finish out an
attack with a duck being such a good
Defender
opponent says oh no my queen
GG
okay the head of chest leaves now
oh Sam's savian in third place wow
who's former prodigy
okay I've avoided all the grand Masters
so far
okay preventing Knight E2 allowing
Knight D5
this could get weird
offering the trade
I think D3 is a nice Square to have the
duck return to
was the queen not trapped
was there some mutual blind spot
Bishop G4
oh the the queen could have moved back
right and then like ducky two
ah
[Music]
very good point
of the mutual blind spot
I can't show her right now but basically
the queen moving back and duck blocking
very good point look at this move
uh let's just move back
foreign
this is a move I was thinking of playing
anyway
opponent provoked me I'm threatening
some other duck mates
I have to be a little bit careful though
I'm allowing Queen B5 yeah
Queen B5 Maybe
how I do this
could get really weird
should be okay for me
I'll block with the duck somehow
and there's a lot of pressure on white I
should have played like Duck B5 or
something
or duck D3
now there's also this move too
oh okay opponent misses
my idea
GG
another smother duck mate
opponent was going for the same thing
but
I take the king first
okay clear first again
there's 384 game a 300 no 154 people
wait does that make sense
that looked like 384 games
not sure what those icons meant
okay new game
playing I have the sauce
I played this person before I already
forget
I want to play D4
maybe like 92
D3
Bishop G5 on the horizon
thank you bling Russ blingy Russ
the first time Prime
okay
happy to trade
I'm guaranteeing Knight D5 next
opponent to bathing which Pawn to take
with
foreign
we're probably going to see this move
and then I'll lightly retreat
oh
this is still coming
I'm hoping for this move
and get another smaller tuck meat
but uh yeah let's play this
going for C3 D4
oops I just hung upon
it's not so bad I don't think
I should look like we need two first
uh what to do
prevent C4
so materialize it looks like I'm down
the pond but I do have one extra Knight
like Knight for Bishop which should be
still in my favor
let's hold on to both nights
I want to play F4
also A4 so at least I had a couple ideas
there
preventing B4
so I'm trying to guarantee the file
opening
and essentially here I want to play on
the queen side and the King side
very important part of duck strategy
and there's rookie seven
let's go for this
I might regret this It looks interesting
though
because I yeah I'll sack
do I want a sack
play F4 too
one's giving me a chance
let's talk first
I don't think it Rooks are so much
better
[Music]
play duck D5
yeah I still can't play F4 unfortunately
it isn't so easy I might be in a little
bit of trouble here
um
okay now I can play F4 and duck C5
Knight D3 is probably coming
F5 is coming for me
or not
okay King G2
need to be patient this is some idea
oh wow there's this move
that almost works
they play my Bishop's defended
to be really careful though
hmm
wait did I miss no
or Palm B3
okay trying to Chisel away
oh wait
I'm still allowing this
oh King G2 is terrible
I'm in big big trouble
no this is really really bad
opponent finds it too
okay well now we're gonna see some Queen
odds
I got two knights
two nights for queen
and Rook
oh dear
wait wait wait undo undo undo
this first
Jason Bishop
no that doesn't work either
this move
I'm guaranteeing Knight D5
yeah here we see the horses come to life
and the most magical way I want to play
Rook A6 as well
or Knight D4
there we go
don't mess with my horsies
okay I think the bishop is like
basically trapped
amazingly enough
that's crazy like how
how much you can fight back from a
material deficit in this game especially
with overseas
okay so I'll take
ensure that I'm winning the bishop next
and the rook's gonna be shut in for a
while
which is nice
time Advantage is also nice
finding Knight D5
heading F6
shelling in The Rook
there's actually just a domination
basically
oh that's a move I can take
on F6
um let's be safe
wow
you're threatening this now
foreign
okay one on time that was a clue scheme
man good game
I got forts in the middle game I had to
fight my way back
again I'm sure there were missed
Aquatics everywhere
usually the nature of duck chess oh
playing that my highest rated opponent
yet
16 or no 1967.
okay I just want to win the pawn
actually curious how Lock's gonna defend
and this Knight can't develop so maybe
maybe if Carol Khan isn't like a great
opening
but this is still very playable for
black
I can't really explain F6
okay so F4 is probably the main way to
expand
so I'll probably go for like some weird
night maneuver
also realizing it would be nice to get a
knight to D6
but that's hard to achieve
when they see Bishop A6 Maybe
I don't think I mined the trade
offering trailer Bishops
okay a couple moves from the smothered
mate
and there's this idea too
never mind
hmm
okay preventing
um
anything coming to E7
I am allowing the d-pawn to move but
then Queen C4
looks interesting
trying to get a grip on the position
[Music]
maybe this move
threading H5
H5 would trap the Knight
and upon each five then black has to
worry about Queen H5
okay so that's some success
play A4
and grab space
curious what blocks up too because
there's already one liability
I don't think it's easy to like develop
a queen side
you probably want to like go for A5 oh
okay
I'm not sure if this is like an
intentional sacrifice
it looks good though
I think box was forgot that each Pawn
needed to be taken care of
if Queen F7
[Music]
actually we'll see what happens I don't
want to say anything
Queen F7 looks like a natural response
and Knight E7 will lose our Rook
yeah Queen L7 that was a good move
let's play this and then this
guaranteeing Pawn H5
if I took I would have had to move the
duck and I'd lose my Knights
so ducky 7 was the only way to defend E6
or defend D6
essentially
oh okay but I have this and then this
so now I have 97
I I smothered duck meat
oh Knight is basically trapped
and the king is prevented from escaping
to safety
and realizing this tournament is going
to end in like five minutes
so this might be the last game that
counts for the tournament
I'll try and get one more after this one
okay so I'm about Rook now
still threatening this idea
which opponent misses
no mercy
that night is still trapped
this could take some time to convert
though
a flag doesn't flag
okay I'm gonna win the a pawn
oops
threatening the Knight and the king and
the bishop
this was a test of my winning technique
um
we're getting closer it takes work to
Checkmate the king even with so many
pieces
uh let's play this
oops
slowly but surely
okay there we go
what happened there we go okay some
suspense towards the end there
oh
okay oh I'm still in first okay this is
definitely going to be the last game
there's two minutes left of the
tournament
um I'm gonna try to try and win as
quickly as possible which is hard to do
in Duck chess
but we'll see what happens
uh let's play this
now the tournament ends in one minute
um
I'm not super proud of this opening
actually
although it's interesting I might be
threatening B2
never mind
I have to prevent Knight D5
okay so I guess the game doesn't get
aborted
like in in the other chess.com Arena
tournaments
[Music]
um
usually when the term ends the game just
gets supported
but I guess this it's not the case here
oh oh it's so close
also I'm in a little bit of trouble
uh
I have to be really careful here
white could taken put the duck on G7
here I can take
so getting some counter play
so this is attacked a lot of things are
attacked
very confusing position actually
the duck is saving my king
it doesn't look like I'm going to hit
2200
but uh had some fun games today
very heroic duck
okay trapping the bishop I mean white
could still take the Knight
I think maybe white assumes the pawn is
pinned
oh wait I have to be careful
take
I really want a sack on C3
let's hold off
yes I mean it wouldn't even be a sack if
I could play 92 the problem is the duck
would land on E2
and I wouldn't have 92
okay so I found the key idea
and this is actually not so good for me
because white has two knights and I I
have two Bishops
um however
I think this Knight is trapped
oh there's might be two though but I'm
hitting the pawn as well
so maybe it is good for me because the
king is
um a bit exposed
that looks like I'll win the pawn next
assuming we see like Knight B2 duck G7
calculating Knight B2 duck G7 Queen E4
and then maybe like Duck D3
or duck E3
duck E3 preventing Queen E3
the material you can see off the board
it's better practice to look at material
on the board though
to get a sense of the imbalances
so I I'm essentially up a pawn
uh I have six against five
but Knights are at least a point better
than Bishops but in this position the
knights aren't so great
like the knights are kind of like
sitting ducks
so I'm finding this this and this
if the king and Knight were in hanging
then Like Queenie and queen D6 ducky 7
could be an option
or we're probably gonna see the queen
move and then duck G4
oh okay I'll take and then save my Rook
so I removed one Sitting Duck
and now
I'll Attack the queen
I mean queen deck Z6 is an option
trying to calculate mating ideas
it's getting close
oh I could have taken and played ducky
one
if I have another idea
okay let's play this
and then B1
why he's gonna have to put the duck on
G1 next move
oh
very clever
play this and this
should I save my queen maybe I should
save my queen
allowing Queen digs Rook
but then this
and the queen covers G2 from a distance
I wanted to play this and this
okay but I have this
and this
it's so close to Nate
but not quite
maybe this
and this
okay this is I think this is me this and
then this
let's go
because the Queen's defended by both the
rook and the bishop
if it was only defended by one thing
then the king could take and then block
but
was there Queen G2 doc F3
uh no I mean there there was it was
legal like in this position Queen G2
duck F3 it looks like Checkmate but it
loses a queen
because uh yeah The Rook is blocked I
mean I wanted to play Queen G2 duck G3
usually this would be a way of mating
but then Queen takes G2
so I hope that answers the question
there's also a question about Queen G2
duck D7
in this position
[Music]
which doesn't work because Queen takes
G7 or King King takes G2
and duck G3
oh so where are the standings
hey let's go
end it in first place